Chile's left-wing Brazilian Gabriel
boric had joined peaceful demonstrators
marching to Santiago's General Cemetery
to pay homage to Fallen former president
Salvador Allende
[Applause]
but suddenly it all turned ugly a group
of men and women in black their faces
covered attacked the crowd and tried to
rush the presidential Palace
many were injured as riot police moved
in
put on the eve of the 50th anniversary
of Chile's 1973 military coup thousands
continued marching to the cemetery many
carrying photos of victims of the former
military dictatorship under General
agusto Pinochet
[Applause]
alier's father was one of them this is
the day remembrance a day of Human
Rights they were we remember what
happened 50 years ago
but the March was interrupted repeatedly
the tear gas is getting much much
stronger here glass bottles and Molotov
cocktails are being thrown back there
but not at the police but rather at some
members of the Socialist and communist
parties that made up part of President
ayend this government 50 years ago but
also the new government of Gabriel
borage president Gabriel borage whom
they are now calling traitor
inside the cemetery itself riot police
brought in water cannon trucks and tear
gas Vans to chase demonstrators even
around the tomb of former president
Allende
at the Museum of memory a more emotional
scene as a survivor of one of the
dictatorship's interrogation and torture
centers embraced Brazilian abando Tejeda
the photographer who had photographed
him in 1973 in a dungeon when he was 15
years old
two weeks ago I saw this photo in a
poster and contacted the Brazilian
embassy because I am a survivor of the
National Stadium incident and that photo
is also my brother Gerardo he was 24
years old and he was never seen again
the commemoration of the overtrow of the
world's first democratically elected
socialist president on September 11
1973 is not over but after half a
century it's a date that continues to
unleash pain and confrontations
to see a Newman Al Jazeera Santiago
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera